he disappeared on August 8th as he was
returning to Hong Kong from mainland
China Simon Chan is an investment
officer at the Scottish development
international section of the British
Consulate and was on a one-day business
trip in Shenzhen his hold of a British
national overseas passport which China
doesn't recognise now his family and
friends are calling under British
government to take action mr. Boris
Johnson I like you and I believe in you
miss Nicholas irken Simon was promoting
Scotland in his duty travel and his
being captured I urge you to and all MPs
and order please save Simon saving Simon
is your number one priority now the
Chinese Foreign Office has confirmed
that Simon Chan is being held in what
it's calling administrative detention in
stringent for an initial period of 15
days but didn't explain why
Simon's family says it hasn't received
any notice of detention the last time
Simon Chan was heard of is when he wrote
a message to his girlfriend saying that
the train was approaching the West
Kowloon station it is in Hong Kong but
it's manned by Chinese immigration
officials border checks are conducted
here not on the mainland and Chinese
laws apply his family says is from here
that he was taken back to the mainland
the announcement of his disappearance
comes as protesters staged a sit-in to
mark one month since an attack by
suspected gang members on them it
happened at the wane long station near
the border with the mainland the
attackers are said to be staunchly
pro-beijing Simon's portrait is now on
the wall among the victims of that day
Michael Moss says he's not surprised his
friend Simon has been detained Simon had
in some academic related activities some
forum centers etc of course those
seminars or those forums would have a
particular stance on the constitutional
reform or the way how Hong Kong moves
forward in terms of political
development
salmon's lawyer says he hasn't been able
to locate him but his case is likely to
feed into the anger and suspicion among
protesters who fear Beijing's growing
influence in Hong Kong but Abdel Hamid
al-jazeera Hong Kong